Target lost billions of dollars because
they tried to have this Pride selection
oh yeah gay mannequins yeah they well
they had all these like Pride children's
shirts and gay children yeah and then
obviously the Bud Light thing with Dylan
Mulvaney they've lost 20 plus billion
dollars that is wild man so we're seeing
that now well we never saw that before
where people are going enough right
enough stop shoving this down
everybody's throat when I go to Target I
don't want to see like
yeah tuck pants where you like they're
designed to help you tuck your dick that
really is the issue does it have to be
out there in front of everybody and
again does it have to be aimed towards
kids